>> Tucker: JUST IN CASE YOU’RE
WONDERING IF A NEW DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS WILL FUND ANY WALL IN
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, WE HAVE AN
ANSWER.
NANCY PELOSI HAS SAID NO CHANCE.
WALLS DON’T WORK, SHE EXPLAINS
AND MORE THAN THAT, THEY’RE
WRONG.
MORALLY WRONG.
WATCH.
>> MOST OF US, SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF, CONSIDER THE WALL
IMMORAL, INEFFECTIVE.
HE ALSO PROMISED MEXICO WOULD
PAY FOR IT.
EVEN IF NEY DID, ITS IMMORAL.
>> Tucker: YOU MAY BE WONDERING,
WHEN DID MORALITY BEGIN TO PLAY
A CENTRAL ROLE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS?
THE ANSWER IS THE DAY THAT NANCY
PELOSI GOT ORDAINED.
PELOSI IS AN ARCHBISHOP IN THE
CHURCH OF PROGRESSIVE SAN
CHURCH OF PROGRESSIVE
SANCTIMONY.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID IS
IMMORAL.
THIS IS A MORAL CHALLENGE.
AN IMMORAL, INCOMPETENT.
>> WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> MORAL RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
NEXT GENERATION.
>> JUST A REFLECTION OF THE WEAK
MORAL AUTHORITY.
>> Tucker: WEAK MORAL AUTHORITY.
THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR
ST. NANCY.
HER MORAL THOUGHT IS ABSOLUTE.
SHE IS A GOOD PERSON.
YOU, UNFORTUNATELY ARE NOT.
SO PAY ATTENTION AS SHE EXPLAINS
AGAIN, A BORDER WALL IS IMMORAL.
FINE.
WE’LL TAKE HER AT HER WORD.
GOD HATES WALLS.
BUT IF WALLS ARE IMMORAL, WHAT
ABOUT FENCES?
OBAMA SEEMED TO LIKE THEM.
>> THE BILL BEFORE US WILL
CERTAINLY DO SOME GOOD.
THEY WILL AUTHORIZE SOME
BADLY-NEEDED FUNDING FOR BETTER
FENCES AND BETTER SECURITY ALONG
OUR BORDERS.
THAT SHOULD HELP STEM SIDE OF
THE TIDE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: BETTER FENCES SAYS
OBAMA.
THAT SOUNDS IMMORAL.
WHAT ABOUT ISRAEL’S SECURITY
WALL?
IT’S BIG AND REAL AND EFFECTIVE.
PELOSI SUPPORTED IT, ACTUALLY.
SHE VOTED FOR A RESOLUTION
DEFENDING THAT WALL FROM U.N.
CONDEMNATION.
IT’S CONFUSING.
MUST HAVE BEEN BEFORE HER
CONVERSION.
NOW THE WALLS ARE IMMORAL, A FEW
LOGICAL QUESTION ARISE.
WHAT ABOUT DOORS?
AND LOCKS?
HOW ABOUT HEDGES OR SECURITY
SYSTEMS OR AIRPORT CHECKPOINTS
OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT
SPECIFICALLY IS DESIGNED TO KEEP
SOME PEOPLE OUT?
WHAT ABOUT THE GATE IN FRONT OF
PELOSI’S WEEKEND HOUSE?
IS ST. NANCY AGAINST THAT?
OF COURSE NOT.
REPUBLICANS OFTEN SAY THE LEFT
OPPOSES BORDERS.
WE’VE SAID THAT MANY TIMES.
IT’S NOT QUITE TRUE.
IN THEIR OWN LIVES, DEMOCRATS
ARE ALL FOR EXCUSESIVETY.
THEY JUST OPPOSE AMERICA’S
BORDERS.
AMERICA IS A SINFUL NATION, THEY
TELL US.
WE CAN ONLY ATONE FOR THOSE SINS
BY GIVING WHAT WE HAVE TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
SO THERE’S A LESSON HERE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THE PRESIDENT GOT ELECTED BY
PROMISING A BORDER WALL.
PEOPLE WANTED THAT.
THEY VOTED FOR HIM.
PRESIDENT PLEDGED THAT IN ALMOST
EVERY SPEECH HE GAVE.
>> I’M GOING TO BUILD A WALL AND
IT’S GOING TO WITH A REAL WALL,
A STRONG WALL.
NOBODY IS COMING THROUGH UNLESS
IT’S LEGAL.
NOBODY, NOBODY.
GOING TO BE A REAL WALL.
NOT A TOY WALL LIKE WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
>> BUILD THE WALL, BUILD THE
WALL!
>> DON’T WORRY, FOLKS.
WE’RE GOING TO BE BUILDING THE
WALL.
>> PAUL RYAN NEVER WANTED A
PELOSI MADE IT CRYSTAL CLEAN
THAT DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER BUILD
ONE.
THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE THE
COUNTRY FALL APART FIRST.
THEY MADE THAT DECISION.
AMERICA’S MIDDLE CLASS IS TYING.
THE BORDER GOES UNSECURITY.
THE NEXT
THREE WEEKS THE FINAL
CHANCE THAT REPUBLICANS WILL
HAVE IN A LONG TIME TO KEEP
THEIR PROMISE ON THE WALL.
IT WOULDN’T BE EASY, BUT IT
WOULD BE POSSIBLE.
DEMOCRATS LOST THE HOUSE IN 2010
AND IN THE SHORT WINDOW BECOME
REPUBLICANS TOOK BACK THE HOUSE,
BARACK OBAMA GOT QUITE A FEW OF
HIS PRIORITIES INTO LAW.
DEMOCRATS REPEALED THE
MILITARY’S BAN ON GAY SERVICE